ten years on Madeline McCann's parents
have been told police are no nearer
solving the mystery of their daughter's
disappearance
for a long time Scotland Yard suspected
Madeline was abducted from the family's
rented holiday apartment during a
burglary one of their suspects was Josie
Carlos de Silva a former driver of the
holiday complex he and others were
identified by their use of mobile phones
their location on the night and their
backgrounds they've all since been ruled
out the theory a burglary that went
wrong somebody's doing a burglary and
panicked maybe by by a waking child and
that's what leads to nothing going
missing so those burglars would run out
wouldn't they in my experience if you
try to apply cold rational logic of a
normal person
sat in their front room - what criminals
do under pressure you tend to make
mistakes so it was a sensible hypothesis
it's still not entirely ruled days
another suspect questioned and ruled out
by British detectives was russian-born
computer specialist Sergei malinka he
was first questioned in 2007 Scotland
Yard was brought in six years ago after
the failed first Portuguese
investigation it has spent more than 11
million pounds of home office funds the
force is receiving new information each
day do you think you're any closer to
solving this than you were 6 years ago
when you started I I think we have I
know we have a significant line of
inquiry which is worth pursuing and
because it's worth pursuing it could
provide an answer in his first British
TV interview a Portuguese police chief
said he was under no pressure to wind up
his own renewed investigation
if the Metropolitan Police decides to
close the English
that doesn't mean that we are going to
close our our two investigations are not
dependent on of each other in a Facebook
message Kate McCann revealed how she was
dreading the anniversary she wrote we
are bracing ourselves for the next
couple of weeks it's likely to be
stressful and painful
we will go on try our hardest never give
up and make the best of the life we have
there will always be hope the mystery of
Madeleine McCann remains just that a
mystery
Martin Brunt Sky News